how are you doing yeah yeah getting
ready for the madness the stretch run in
October okay does September mean
anything if you're playing really good
or really bad in your opinion no the
only thing it means is if you have a
young player or two getting ready for
the postseason for the first time I'd
rather him him individually be doing
well rather than coming in oh for twenty
or losing his last four games but for a
team it's look you could win fifteen and
row and the season ends you're gonna
have five days off yeah so it doesn't
mean as much I'm not a big believer in
that I would rather have players that
have never experienced a postseason have
success leading into it versus the other
more impressive or surprising that the
Dodgers would have an 11 game losing
streak or that the Indians would win 20
in a row man they're both polar
opposites of what a yet what you ever
think could happen I never thought the
Dodgers they're gonna go through their
bad stretch but I'd never thought they'd
lose 15 out of 16 11 in a row Kershaw
twice pitching so to me that's more that
is what what what they were doing is
more shocking than the fact that
Cleveland which is incredible has gone
on to win 21 games I look at Cleveland
because they went to the World Series
they were one win away from winning the
World Series that okay they got on a
great run and okay I'm not as surprised
with that it's still phenomenal but the
Dodgers losing 11 in a row after people
ready to christen them the greatest team
of all time that to me is what's
surprising but if you're Dave Roberts
are the Dodgers how do you say to your
team forget about that like that you
know that that's an anomaly that's an
aberration that's not who we are even
though you went through this yeah it's
hard you know I when you're going good
you don't have to you just pass the
baton on no one feels like they have to
pitch a shutout for the Indians but when
you're going bad everybody individually
thinks I got a pitch a shutout and you
start pressing in ways that even the
great teams go through a stretch that I
think will benefit them in the long run
not that anyone wants to lose 10 or 11
in a row but he's got some veteran guys
so on the Dodgers if Bellinger and some
of the young guys start experiencing
long droughts that
because earn me a little bit but this is
a very good team that's gonna line up
four days after the posts after the
season starts with Kershaw I think I'd
feel good but you also look at the
Indians and now they're all in on this
winning streak it's like when the Miami
Heat had that winning streak now
everybody's got to play in every game is
important and it's important for the
Indians where you're not gonna be
resting somebody taking somebody out of
the rotation giving somebody a day off
because you have a chance to continue to
make history you do and I think more
than that you have a chance to get which
was concealed yeah that was that was not
even within the reach now you're forced
to think about that and rightfully so if
this was a week to go in the season or
three days to go I don't think they put
as much emphasis on this health would be
number one because they've secured
everything but the fact that they can
play and they have played without three
starters they've played without Andrew
Miller they've allowed a lot of young
guys to check in what I think is the
most impressive thing about the streak
is Bauer now feels like he is where he
should be like when I talk about a
streak Bauer and Clevenger the two guys
that have benefited because you didn't
have them at this level last year now
Bauer thinks he's not gonna lose that's
an awesome feeling for the Indians
Clevenger same thing you've got a more
balanced pitching staff than they had
last year and you got Kluber - yeah
Kluber just he's possibly gonna win
another site young he's in as big and as
good as a groove you'll ever see and boy
he gets so excited too when he pisses
you know it's like I wish he would own
down the emotions he's awesome now I
love watching him pitch and he was so
pressed up against last year he had to
try to pitch well he pitched on three
days rest I think for different time but
did you how much of your aggression
because he has a personality I'm sure
but he doesn't show it at all any flat
lines right at all when you were on the
mound can your ego get the better of you
did you allow your ego to get the better
of you oh yeah early on I had to learn
somewhere between you know Glavine and
Denny Neagle is where I needed to be
because I was a more of an emotional guy
I fed off of that and I learned how to
be I learned how to hide some of it
because I wasn't good early on I let my
emotions show and where
Kluber is is more like Glavine very
stoic you're not gonna know what's going
on inside and you're not gonna know if
he's got a his if he doesn't have it
that day but then you want to throw a
fastball by a guy like you right you got
a lot show on the mound did yeah yeah
and I learned I learned how to channel
that to what I loved about the
postseason I wish I could have had in
the regular season but I could have
never made it out of been there's no way
I could pitch a regular season game like
I did a postseason game it's almost
stored up energy stored up adrenaline
and I will loved it so much that I
wanted more of that than I wanted of the
regular-season games but when you get to
that point there is a channeled energy
that hopefully most guys can go to if
not you will be more ramped up and you
will be more you will you'll give into
situations you wouldn't you wouldn't
have done in the regular season you've
faced a lot of Hall of Famers and it's
weird how we look at a pitcher you could
get him out seven out of ten times but
people are gonna remember yeah didn't he
take you deep oh yeah all right which
what bothers you does somebody bring up
something where you go yeah but I got
him out too I struck him out yeah I mean
interestingly enough I had decent
average numbers against Barry Bonds but
they bring up that both he and I and
Maddux gave up the most home runs to him
nine home runs and you know that that
the playoffs he never really got me when
it when it mattered nice oh that doesn't
matter they say hey give hugs to Barry
Bonds the one that gets me honestly that
I still think that I was so all right so
it's back in the old st. Louis Stadium
I'm closing I thought I was coming in
the game in the eighth inning with two
outs in a one-run game and instead I
came into the eighth inning after a tie
game on the road as the closer and I'm
not kidding you I was so mad it was back
in left-field I walked through chippers
playing left field Albert Pujols is up
tie game and he says something to me and
I said don't even get me started that's
a wrong mindset to come into a game I'm
so mad that I'm in this game at the
point that I am so you're not it's a
closeout situation it's a tie game yeah
I had been up it was 2 to nothing and I
think Horacio Ramirez is pitching gem he
gave up a solo home run I flipped the
ball to the bullpen
coach because Bobby came out I knew I
was coming in well I didn't come in so I
sat down and then he gave up another run
and now I'm coming in and so I'm as mad
as I've ever been
poo horses at the plate I tried to throw
a hundred miles an hour and he hit it to
the bigmack land we lost the game and
the worst part about it there's a in the
clubhouse the old clubhouse they had
these curtains that separated the locker
room to the training room and for some
reason I looked at the curtains as if
they were laughing at me and I attacked
these curtains with both hands and I
tried to rip them off the hinge they
were metal reinforced and I had on the
plane flight two ice bags on both my
thumbs I thought I broke my thumb so
that didn't go well at all and I learned
a huge lesson of aggression well in this
role does not play well and luckily I
didn't break my thumbs would you have
made up a story to the media if it had
kept you out of it out of an appearance
Wow
yeah I would have just I would have
probably been brutally honest even
though I'm brutally honest about
something that never happened to me that
was in Sports Illustrated I don't think
at this point doesn't matter right but
it but you brought it up water steamer
and then you bring that up today by the
way how many people think that I had
ironed a shirt while I was wearing it
it's just such a joke and I didn't run
with that 25 years ago you gotta stay
with it John I should have made a
marketing out of it you missed the boat
on that one but but once again it was a
steamer you have a portable steamer you
didn't burn yourself oh is the little
watermark that everyone thought I had it
turned into like three heal burns all
over my body or degree burns yeah yeah
if I would have probably been honest to
a fault there and said that I the
curtains were lap metal then it would be
curtains foiled again
Smoltz Gibbs up homerun to Albert
Poole's yes Paulie I just googled John I
found at least 40 stories that say
you once missed a star because you hired
a shirt whilst wearing it and burnt your
chest yeah I know it's unbelievable at
least 40 I'm like I thought I've dropped
a little bit I was the third dumbest any
time someone does something to Trump me
I go down the list a little bit what is
the best excuse you heard for somebody
you don't have to give names but
somebody who missed time they got hurt
did did you have I couldn't believe some
of them like okay wait let's take a
break all right but and if it's teammate
I don't want you to you know not anybody
but if you do it's better radio okay so
we'll talk about the excuses that guys
because I Rob Dibble told me one where a
guy was out drinking at night and he
stepped off the curb and either broke
his ankle or sprained his ankle really
bad they got him to the ball park the
next day afternoon at Wrigley and then
he fell quote-unquote in the outfield
during BP and then they went oh god skip
come out and check this out so he made
it seem like he put on his uniform with
a you know an ankle that's like a
grapefruit and they dragged him out like
weekend at Bernie's and then all of a
sudden he's fallen in the outfield all
right we'll come back with John Smoltz
MLB Network after this before I get too
embarrassing injuries and guys who made
up stories on your team or maybe other
teams that you heard of I did want to
ask you about stealing signs with the
Red Sox and the Yankees still haven't
gotten any kind of decision which I hope
baseball doesn't treat it the way
football does right and this would be
you know a year-long process here is
there is there really something that's
that definitive a right way and a wrong
way to steal signs I mean I think there
is I don't think there's anything that's
in the rule books but when you when
you're brought up in the game and you
understand the physical standpoint of
seeing something and translating that to
your teammate that's that's something
that you know if you're gonna if you're
gonna give away signs like a pitcher
gives away signs with his glove or his
mouth or anything and if a hitter goes
out I'm sorry I'm not gonna I'm sorry
no that's part of the game and if the
catcher can't decode his signs or the
pitcher catcher cannot get out that is
part of what we've always understood was
part of taking advantage of within the
game technology now that's a different
thing because technology finally came
into the game where you see iPads on the
bench so that a batter or pitcher could
look at previous at-bats or previous now
they're not there's no way to kind of
utilize that for because it's only
confined to that but when you have
technology like a watch or if you go
underneath see we used to chart all the
time in the in the clubhouse and you're
seeing the signals of signs just like if
a man on second yeah so if you don't
change those or decoding that that's
that's on you but I think the the
technology part that that's not on you
that's that's something that has to be
addressed did you guys steal signs yeah
and we lost 110 get 104 games we were so
proud of stealing oh my god we had orel
hershiser x' pitches during his streak
so 1988 yeah he shut us out we had every
pitch new what was coming with Hershiser
and still couldn't touch yeah so we were
so bad that one of our goals was if we
can steal signs maybe give us a better
chance who's at the plate and I got the
sign for the first time it was very
limited batter and I knew a fastball was
coming and I came out of my shoes I hit
a home run but I hit it to right field I
couldn't still pull the ball but I was
so excited I wanted to hug the guy that
gave me size he's like stop stop stop
stop
you know don't don't be so blatant but
those are the things when as a nerd be
surprised how many wait wait you you
homered off Hershiser no no this was
also another okay when you when he is a
hitter when you know San arias coming or
eliminated if you know the pitch is
gonna be in a certain area that
eliminates certain pitches so you can
you can actually give yourself a better
chance now there's very it's surprising
how many guys don't want to know what's
coming for fear that they might be wrong
meaning you sell out for a fastball or a
slider and but yeah the part of trying
to get an advantage on the field has a
way of taking care of itself too as long
as you're not so blatant and third-base
coach is like walking to the dugout when
it's a fastball or certain things like
that
did you tip your pitches oh yeah yeah I
had how long did it take for somebody
when do you know that you're tipping
your pitches when you can't figure out
what's going wrong and they're
absolutely tattooing balls meaning it's
it's translating from team to team so
one team beats you up no big deal second
team does in the third team does you're
like something's going on I had the most
enjoyable golf tournament conversation
with a guy who had a few drinks in him
who told me that we have your pitches
and I went oh my gosh thank you I was
been wondering about that the year was
over he goes we got your pitches but
it's not coming from you it's coming
from your catcher I know what oh that's
evil to fix that in a nice little golf
tournament postseason all right some
injury the best injury cover-up for an
injury that you had that you heard was
well you know that's the interesting
part when the cover-up part I'm gonna
speak I think they knew I did this I was
a basketball coach in the offseason so
my first couple years with the Braves I
coached freshman basketball loved it had
a time in my life and I would train and
play with the players it's the last
practice of the week of the of the year
and I'm going to spring training they
said coach come on do the drill we
always do it I can't take these chances
I got to go to big-league camp they come
on coach they did it I rolled my I
thought I broke my ankle and I went into
the training room table table I couldn't
fly it was horrible and I went to spring
training and tried to do everything I
could and did those drills and my ankle
kept blowing up and and I said well I
got to be honest I was training in the
offseason running the stairs and I
rolled my ankle I was scared to death
they knew exactly what happened see
Laura I did lie and I and I'm glad to
get that off my chest actually after all
these years of this first time you told
it it is now but you feel better Dane
you explain this to me AJ Pierzynski you
played catcher for what 19 years and in
the major leagues he said that he would
see Glavine and Maddux get like a foot
off the plate and get those calls and he
said he was fine with that because they
had earned it yeah
now why do I give the best players Hall
of Fame pitchers 300 game winners more
credit
than a guy who's just trying to hang on
in the major leagues on a roster well I
think obviously having watched them my
whole career they put so much pressure
and were so precise that the pressure on
us on the strike zone for the umpire
when a catcher's not moving his glove
consistently is unbelievable and yes the
strike zone was different back then I
think anybody in that era who could
throw the ball to an area consistently
we're going to get more calls and put
pressure on and I think the fact that
they were probably the tube that
everyone goes to because they were so
good that in any strike zone they would
have flourished knowing where to go to
get that extra inch or two hmm it's like
Jordan getting the dig calls maybe but I
also know that when they made a specific
change over those two it was tougher
transition for Glavine until he realized
he could still you know that's when they
changed the strike zone and they were
gonna call the strike zone and he
struggled for a while but then he
adapted because anybody who is good
enough to to do what they were doing
before could learn to do it differently
explain what it's like and I don't know
Pujols was in the same category as bonds
but pool holds that first 10 years with
the Cardinals was was pretty incredible
well what was it like though and I know
it's right hander on right hander I
don't know if that was that big of a
benefit to you but going in and facing
Pujols was how was that I felt like I
could get any right-hander out in the
big leagues I really felt that way until
this guy by Fame a pool shows up because
he was so comfortable he you know it's
it's an eerie reminder of Gary Sanchez
reminds me of pools the way he said yeah
the way he sits in the box and the way
he waits and he has so much power but
pools was literally the Machine where
until later in my career I figured out I
could open a door here and do something
different I felt helpless I felt I felt
like he just knew what was coming he he
never exerted his body he never got out
in front and I don't mind saying that he
was the scariest right-handed hitter
that could do everything that you didn't
want a hitter to do off of you he didn't
have a weakness and that's why he was so
great for ten years plus it
you you had to have him get himself out
yeah yeah I mean the thing that that
people forget and even with like Aaron
judge the pitchers were so afraid of
Aaron judge in the first half that they
couldn't get the ball where they wanted
to and he crushed everything well he
expands the zone a little bit and it's
not that the pitchers found they're
found weaknesses they just were more at
they it was almost like oh we can do
this we can go down in a way we can go
up so it freed them up a little bit and
that a hitter either exposes himself at
times and then learns how to adjust but
he helped the whole league out by saying
oh he's human and we can go here because
in the first half they were more coaxed
into errors than they were coaxed into
being aggressive now that you're seeing
a different approach in the second half
when Bonds hit 73 and he's what walked
two hundred and some right I don't know
how many he I'm guessing he could have
hit if you pitch to him he's hitting 90
home runs yes people don't understand
they don't understand he did he got one
pitch in it back and didn't miss it and
if he didn't get the pitch he walked he
totally changed a lineup that I would
argue was not that good of a lineup
but he made them that lineup so much
better because he did take his walk he
would get mad and steal if he needed to
he the game was being taken from him
because he was so good at that point and
he wanted guys to challenge him but he
knew if he challenged you
if you challenged him he was gonna
embarrass you that's how good and locked
in he was the one I had to pitch during
that time where he was looking to break
the record I had to go in there his
locker room to get actually worked on by
a different guy and he saw me and it was
the worst thing that I didn't I didn't
want him to see me I'm pitching that
game and we had kind of a different
relationship or we're where we drasi
each other and he went off on me saying
not in my house Smoltz you pitched to me
you understand don't you not pitch to me
and I and I survived it I did get him I
pitch to him and I pissed to him pitch
to him a lot which is probably by I have
nine home runs even if he was cheating
to still do what he
did getting one pitch per it bad it's
unbelievable and did because there were
other guys who've cheated too and
they're not coming close to what he was
doing not even close and and look I I
pitched on my whole career and III
unashamedly say was the best player I've
ever seen and pitched against I didn't
pitch against ken griffey jr. all those
years that he was the best in the
American League I only got Ken Griffey
jr. later in his career and what Barry
could do with Pittsburgh what he could
do obviously as he progressed in the
game he was the triple threat he was
he's everything that you didn't want
when I hit her stood in the box he's
John Smoltz Hall of Famer Major League
Baseball Network analyst here's some of
the injuries John is on this list so
Roger Craig of the Giants manager cut
his hand on a bra strap I'm assuming it
wasn't his bra strap but he's on this
list Mickey Tettleton once missed action
because athlete's foot he tied his shoes
too tight
mmm Ryan Klesko your former teammate he
pulled a muscle picking up a lunch tray
really he's on there yeah yeah klesko's
on here the drone in incident last year
is gonna go yeah no Bret Barberie missed
a game after he got chili juice in his
high you know back in the day I always
he drinking when he got chili juice in
his eye when the hot foot was such a big
thing you know where you like the guy's
shoes yeah my teammate back in a ball
got me in so much trouble because why is
it when you see fire on a shoestring you
put it out with your fingers especially
your pitching hand what makes you think
that that's a good idea and that's
exactly that he got blisters and missed
his start and I got in trouble did you
ever do hot foot in the major leagues oh
yes oh my gosh when we were losing 104
games what else was here to do but you
couldn't do that to Maddox and risk you
know like burning up his leg or
something he wouldn't put it out with
his pitching hand I can tell you that
but he was worse he would have done it
to other people wouldn't he know he was
far too cerebral to do something like a
hot foot he wouldn't do hot foot he
would do things that but but we were we
got we eventually had to get it
because he got so bad that we called it
the Train like if I was going to give
you a hot foot and you were playing
cards so I snuck behind you so I'm on my
hands and knees my feet are exposed the
guy behind me is doing mine while the
guy behind him is doing his it got out
of hand and too much free time man
once we started winning we stopped the
hot ok your World Series picks well you
know when you have these beginning of
the year you pick two teens and you
think you know what you're doing and
obviously now broadcasting am i I
realize I I get to broadcast them but I
don't know in the beginning of the year
I did I did see Boston in LA obviously
there's always going to be things that
change and matchups are so key to how
you get to the end in the World Series
who you avoid because for example in the
National League if you're the Washington
Nationals and now you have a chance to
get the best record and you can avoid
going through the Cubs and the Dodgers
yeah that's different then so it's it's
this is what I like now broadcasting the
games and getting a chance to do it
there will not be a bad matchup and
that's what we saw last year and I think
we're gonna see it again the wild-card
and American League with the Yankees
kind of putting themselves in a position
to win the division and secure
themselves they're a dangerous series
team meaning if they get in a series
they're dangerous and that bullpen yes
and the fact is though if they have to
get through the one game play in game I
think it makes them a little less
dangerous and that's what the wild card
game is has has been therefore to try to
give a disadvantage to that team who has
to play one game John good to see you
hallways great that you go stop in and
have fun during the postseason thank you
I'll keep an eye out now I'm looking to
move down in the ranks actually in this
in this dumb and dumb dumb entry but
you're you're immortalized yeah it's
true but maybe I can encourage a couple
guys to do something do something stupid
but for the record John did not matter a
shirt while it was always wad it was a
steamer yeah a portable steamer portable
steamer you get a sponsorship out of
that couldn't you you know I could you
could have had you embraced it you could
have Arsenio Hall had me on
the air you went online EO to talk about
it no that's what happened right when
the word when that when it news broke I
would made our City Hall he talked about
he said no wonder the Braves can't win
here he said this Josh moult's guy
burned himself ironing a shirt the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience